i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him
and all of my relationship to date with
johnny
i hadn't landed a blow
okay so the johnny depp versus amber
head trial is now in a recess after
hitting the midpoint of amber's
testimony last week i know lots of you
have been asking for update videos but i
really wanted to treat this subject as
carefully as i can as this is a very
sensitive subject that has a lot of
ramifications for abuse victims due to
it being in the public eye if i get an
easter egg wrong on a marvel video then
people will have a go in the comments
but with this if i put a foot wrong it's
way way worse i've had tons of comments
from people saying that unsubscribing
for me just even covering it but this is
counted by the amount of people that
have asked me to go over it the thing
with youtube is that no matter what you
do people are gonna complain and even a
video like my squid game breakdown had 3
000 people unsubscribed from the channel
because of it so just being as
respectful and objective as possible in
this video and throughout it we're going
to be going over the updates since we
dropped our last one instead of
discussing amber's testimony per se i'm
going to be doing what we did with
johnny and discussing the reaction to it
from lawyers behaviour experts and
people who have far more insight on the
topic than i do i'll also be covering
the ones we miss such as travis mcgivin
a hollywood executive as well as amma's
personal psychologist before moving on
to her testimony now last week opened
with a big move by amber after she fired
her entire pr team due to a string of
bad headlines public opinion on the
trial definitely seems to be in johnny's
favor and since acquiring the new team
there's been clear attempts by them to
try and shift the narrative several
newspapers have posted her statements in
the testimony as truth rather than
allegations and there's also been
several times throughout the last two
weeks where hashtag i stand with amber
heard has trended online i'm sure most
of you watching this know depp lost a
libel case with the sun and
interestingly this case might have shown
that the newspaper did indeed make stuff
up in her testimony heard ended up
bringing forth pictures of the bruises
she claimed she sustained from depths
abuse placing these side by side with
the sun's front page you can see that
they in fact photoshop them adding to
the idea that the media definitely
jumped to her side in order to enforce
this notion now travis mcgivern who
worked as johnny depp security guard did
a two-hour testimony talking about their
relationship and what he witnessed what
do you recall miss heard saying in those
instances
deadbeat dad
washed up you name it miss heard didn't
like my involvement in the situation and
what did she say to you in that instance
a lot
one-sided conversation but she basically
demeaned my career choice
called me uh
yes man
yeah she she definitely threw some
shade on me and and my chosen career
what if any injuries did you observe on
misheard that day
i didn't notice any injuries and what if
any injuries did you observe on mr depp
when he returned from australia so mr
depp had his hand heavily wrapped
he requested i meet him at penthouse
five
requested that i bring the nurse
and at some point i witnessed miss heard
throw a red bull can they were both on
the the middle level and i i saw miss
heard throw a red bull can from her
position that struck mr depp in the back
anything else that you recall at that
point i moved closer to mr death i
didn't want my client getting hit with
anything else at one point miss heard
through something else either a purse or
some sort of bag or something that she
had up there i was able to knock it away
so it didn't hit him at one point she
spit at him
i felt it was time to get mr depp out of
the situation so i stepped in between
miss herd and mr telling mr depp that we
were that we were leaving and that it
wasn't up to him anymore at that point
out of the corner of my eye i saw a fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder and uh i heard
and saw a closed fist
contact mr depp in the left side of his
face
and whose fist was that
that was misheard's fifth amber herd's
fist respond when he was punched the
initial look on his face kind of
mirrored mine uh kind of a look of shock
like what just happened where'd that
come from
at that point
i wasn't gonna let mr depp get hit
anymore so i moved him down the last
flight of stairs and told him we're
leaving it like it wasn't it wasn't up
to him anymore just for his safety again
i had let him get hit by a red bull can
i let him get punched my job is to
ensure the safety and well-being of my
clients felt like i hadn't done that so
mr depp
got right in my face he was wearing
sunglasses
and uh maybe not sunglasses he was
wearing glasses um
pulled him down pointed to the left side
of his face and told me that's your
fault what did you see on the left side
of mr depp's face
it was there was already a nice little a
nice little shiner definitely swollen
and red it wasn't black and blue yet but
it was definitely swollen and red at any
point during this incident did mr depp
throw anything it misheard no at any
point did mr depp throw anything at
anyone no at any time during this
incident did mr depp physically respond
to miss hurd no what if any injuries did
you observe i misheard that evening i
didn't notice any injuries in your time
working for mr depp have you ever seen
mr depp physically abuse miss hurd i
have not the only time i would say i've
seen mr deb drunk was uh when he would
fall asleep on the couch sitting up with
his boots on other than that mr depp
handles his liquor very well so pretty
damning and we also had a personal nurse
to amber who discussed amber at length
as well as the allegations made by her
on that occasion he observed that she
did she had a bloody lift correct
correct and she told you that that was a
result of
um the altercation with mr duck right
right do you recall miss her never
telling you that she thought mr duff was
um cheating on her
no i don't recall that specifically i
just
as i said have a general sense of
remembering
jealousy
being an issue
in the testimony she talked about being
sent the photographs of amber's injuries
and also the bruised lip which she
examined the nurse said that she
referred amber to be checked out by a
professional physician but that she was
often ignored she also brought up her
drug abuse and i'm not entirely sure she
benefited either side she did seem to
confirm elements of both stories and
also discussed amer's bipolar disorder
which is something that was brought up
by dr curry who we'll talk more about in
just a bit now as much as this trial is
devolved into an abuse one the focus
seems to have shifted from the
defamation side of it which is what the
law suit is actually over it's very easy
to get caught up in the more headline
grabbing things but at the core of it is
this idea that because of herd's piece a
johnny depp lost a lot of roles in
hollywood this was discussed by richard
marks a hollywood executive who went
over the ins and outs of depp's
perception in the industry the metoo
movement
well i would say
the bigger the company the bigger the
budgets
they're all sensitive
but
at the pinnacle of sensitivity are the
family friendly companies like disney
uh they're particularly sensitive
not in a general way but in a very
specific way
mr marks are you familiar with the op-ed
misheard published in the washington
post on december 18 2018
yes
what's your understanding of how that
op-ed was received in hollywood
my understanding of how that op-ed was
received in hollywood
sir is this his personal understanding
his expert understanding that it seems
like if it's his personal understanding
it's not relevant
i'm asking mr marks based on his nearly
50 years in the understanding of
objection thank you
as i've said before i am a member of the
hollywood community
that
op-ed
for the first time is in
a mainstream publication
called the washington post this is a
flagship
journal if you will of american news
we're not talking about a trade paper
we're not talking about a rag we're
talking about the washington post
and it
it is geared
to hollywood it says
two years ago when i was
getting my
divorce amber heard is saying
uh i i
was the abuser and you didn't hollywood
you you stood up for my uh uh abuser not
for rejection
he's now he's mischaracterizing the
document
i think he's he's expressing his
understanding of how it was personal
objection
what i'm saying is hollywood got the
the subject matter the loud of the of
the op-ed loud and clear
amber heard was calling out hollywood
for
supporting uh
since night since 2016 supporting her
abuser
and uh
she felt the wrath of hollywood she was
calling them out to do something
in the washington post
and
on the eve
of her biggest
film
a big film for hollywood
the publicity machine was in high gear
there was
lots of publicity and uh
news out there
this was the height of of her fame
and she used it at that moment to call
hollywood out they uh
in my opinion as a member of hollywood
they heard uh that plea loud and clear
uh and um
it also got her publicity for her movie
uh you know
i don't think that that
in my perception and people in hollywood
didn't see that as a coincidence that
date
uh and um
so yeah in in hollywood i think um uh
the the message was received that she
was sending this was a really
interesting statement that went through
hollywood's reaction to the metoo
movement marx later went on to say that
in his belief hollywood had a complete
no tolerance policy to any accusations
of abuse at the time and that several
actors were like go because the metoo
movement was so strong that they simply
didn't want to deal with the optics of
working with abusers it was also
discussion of johnny's reputation before
the op-ed which herd's team tried to use
to show that it might not have been that
that caused his careers downfall i've
discussed in other videos their strategy
and how they're not only trying to
deflect but also show that dev did these
things which is a route that they took
here personally i think this attack
failed as marx basically broke down the
way that hollywood dealt with actors but
i'll let you make up your own mind with
this new clip now you would agree that
there was negative publicity about mr
depp being publicly drunk before the
op-ed correct
there was i i agree with the proposition
that there was negative publicity before
the op-ed the op-ed was something
different
and you agree
as in
in 2014 there was an article in the
guardian that said apparently drunk
johnny depp cut off at hollywood film
award ceremony would you agree with that
again i i don't remember reading the the
guardian
and i don't remember that particular
incident but i i'll take you
at your word and you you remember in
looking through all the documents that
you saw an article that johnny depp
allegedly showed up drunk to movie
premiere reports say right that was in
2017.
i
i think i've testified that
there there is certainly
johnny depp behavior and and uh
negativity out there yes
and
that a family that a family that a
family production studio like disney
wouldn't want to be associated with
correct
uh
again
you're talking about a very specific uh
you know um
series of five films that earn billions
of dollars
uh and there is a line in hollywood as
i've said
they'll put up with divas and drugs to
make money
but now we've drawn a line in hollywood
at
the
domestic and sexual abuse and looking
through the documents you saw the
articles in june of 2018 that said vodka
for breakfast 72-hour drug binges and
spending sprees that beggar belief you
saw that
again i
i know these articles exist i know
they're not in the washington post i
don't know what article you're referring
to who wrote it uh you know what
publication it was in but i know that
those articles exist and you'd agree
that before the op-ed mr death had a run
of movie flops wouldn't you agree
every actor has uh you know ups and
downs mr depp is his career's been
decades long
you would agree that in in january of
2015 there was an article that said
johnny depp is on his way to becoming
the most overpaid actor in hollywood
again you'd have to show me the article
but i don't doubt that some uh
commentator
trying to trade on being a smartie pants
wrote that and you'd agree that there
was another article in 2015 that says
quote has johnny depp become hollywood's
biggest joke
i don't know netflix has a whole
festival going now netflix is a joke and
you'd agree that there's an article in
business insider from 2015 that says
johnny depp has his fifth box office
bomb in a row
if that's what it said it said are you
just going to keep uh reading well i
mean this is mr depp's reputation that's
what you're talking about in terms of in
terms of hollywood correct and in 2016
december of 2016 there's a quote there's
an article that says quote johnny depp
is hollywood's most overpaid actor for
the second year in a row did you recall
reading that
i know was that written by the second uh
uh underpaid actor and you would agree
that before the op-ed there was a
negative publicity for mr depp about
assassinating president trump you agree
no i missed that one you didn't see an
article in the new york times that said
johnny depp flirts with idea of trump
assassination that apologizes uh yeah
again
johnny depp talks with the irony and uh
pinash and uh i don't particularly
remember that i have a lot of stuff in
front of me disney wouldn't want to be
disney wouldn't want to be involved with
somebody who's calling for the
assassination of the president would it
i'm sure after those articles
johnny depp was involved in a major
studio projects do you know one way or
the other whether mr depp was involved
in major studio projects after june 23
2017
uh
i i think uh
again i've i haven't quoted his imdp
db page to memory but he was in um
an animated film called sherlock gnomes
i think it was released paramount is one
of the producers i think was released in
2017 user uh in those years uh there was
also the other side of the coin but the
op-ed that didn't mention mr deaf at all
and didn't mention any accusations that
what happened to her that's what caused
mr depp reputational all his
reputational harm that's what you're
saying well i don't agree that uh
this article was not about
did you mention that that's what i asked
you
well does she have another husband who
abused her but didn't talk about it did
you talk at all about mr depp's abuse
objection your honor he's tried to
answer the first question which was not
exactly what the second question was
that he reacts to audacity
yeah ask your question
so yeah mark said that drugs and alcohol
depths career highs and lows weren't
really factors in deciding if he got
jobs and that it was more than no
tolerance to abuse that the industry
took we have talked about hurts team and
the way they question witnesses and yeah
to me he was very leading here
constantly interrupting marks when he
was delivering actually interesting
points and very much going about it the
wrong way in my opinion now as things
develop further we hit the point where
amber and her team tried to have the
case thrown out of court though i
thought this was pretty stupid i
actually had a lawyer contact me just
after this saying it's a pretty common
strategy that fails 99 of the time but
teams just try it because they can
another they actually thought the notion
would pass and yeah it was just kind of
them going through the motions trying to
get the case thrown out on the off
chance that it would be next we had dr
dawn hughes a psychologist who basically
said the exact opposite to what dr curry
said she was definitely on the side of
amber and said that deb abused her and
she attempted to shut down the idea that
she was the one at fault gonna play two
parts of her as she was accused of being
very biased towards women and she was
challenged on using male pronouns like
he and him to describe abusers whilst
using her and she to describe victims
i'll then be following this up with a
breakdown by core tv went over the
differences between both her statement
and dr curry's huge shout out to core tv
as well for compiling these clips and
definitely go check out their channel as
they've got some great stuff on the case
you testified yesterday that you have to
give
careful attention
to gendered stereotypes
that is correct
uh when you're talking about
intimate partner violence you have to
pay attention to gendered stereotypes
and during your testimony you in fact
paid attention
to gendered stereotypes correct
i'm not sure what you mean well
you said we were going to have to pay
attention to gendered stereotypes
and then you testified at length
where you referenced both men and women
you paid attention to those stereotypes
during the course of your testimony
correct
what i was saying was you have to pay
attention to gendered stereotypes when
you're conducting these evaluations you
can't assume all the time that the male
is the perpetrator and the female is the
victim you have to go into the
evaluation understanding that the male
also could be the victim of intimate
partner violence in fact you're aware
that there are large-scale studies that
do say that ipv towards males does exist
of course
okay
and every time
you referred to the characteristic of a
victim
of intimate partner violence yesterday
you used the pronouns she or her didn't
you
i was using the she and her pronouns in
this case because my determination was
as i stated that miss heard was the
victim of intimate partner violence that
is why i was using the she her pronouns
you in fact said women gets into the
relationship for all the right reasons
that's what you said the woman gets into
the relationship for all the right
reasons
then you say difficult
for her for victim to
extricate herself
you go on to say that she can and she
should over and over you use sheep right
i believe in this case i did because i
was referencing this case where i found
misheard to be the victim of intimate
partner violence it doesn't mean that
men don't get into the relationships for
all the right reasons too i believe they
do
so she is kind of giving her excuse for
why she did it there and a lot of people
are very torn on this now she did throw
a lot of shots curry's way and curry
will be called back to the stand again
to go over what she thinks and we'll no
doubt be touching upon this again as her
last testimony was so interesting and
what did the evaluation consist of
so as i stated the evaluation consisted
of a psychological testing
a semi-structured clinical interview
with miss heard a review of a whole host
of documents relative to this case and
medical records and psychological
records and then three collateral
interviews two with her treating
therapist dr bonnie jacobs dr connell
cohen and also with her mom
and in the semi-structured clinical
interview what were you assessing
well when someone comes in for the
evaluation you sometimes don't know what
you're going to see or what you're going
to get so you absolutely have to do a
full clinical interview and have a sense
of their life their life patterns things
that have affected them in their lives
you know where they have worked where
they have lived just get a full sense of
their um their sort of being before the
incident for which they're talking about
then i do a full intimate partner
violence assessment looking at all those
characteristics that i talked to you
about earlier to get a sense of the full
structure of and the dynamic of this
relationship
i also did
looking at what were the effects what
were the psychological consequences of
being in that relationship and i also
looked at the psychological consequences
of some of the statements
that were made by mr depp through his
attorney that are part of this uh the
counter claim in this lawsuit
at the end of that process considering
all the data
did you arrive at any expert opinions
yes i did
all right i'm going i'd like to start
with your main expert opinions and then
go through those can you please tell the
jury what your main opinions were
um so like i said there are opinions
embedded within them but the main
opinion is that ms heard's report of
intimate partner violence
and the records that i reviewed is
consistent with what we know in the
field about intimate partner violence
characterized by physical violence
psychological aggression
sexual violence coercive control
and surveillance behaviors
and what was the other uh main opinion
that you had
the second main opinion was that
that misheard demonstrated very clear
psychological
and traumatic effects or the
exacerbation of trauma from those
statements that mr depp made through his
attorney there were three statements
that we evaluated to see how they
affected her emotionally and
psychologically and it was in my
determination that they did
and did you arrive at any diagnostic
conclusions yes i did and what were
those
i diagnosed uh misheard with
post-traumatic stress disorder
uh and what if any etiology
was associated with the post-traumatic
stress disorder so the ideology is the
cause um in order to have a to meet
criteria for post-traumatic stress
disorder you have to have an actual
cause it's one of the few diagnoses
diagnostic entities that we have to have
a cause for and um the cause was the
intimate partner violence by mr depp
that was the what was pushing the
symptoms that was what related to the
intrusive phenomena that was related to
her avoidance that was elated to her um
differences in her mood that was related
to her avoidance efforts
so it was the the cause was the intimate
partner violence by mr deb
all right now earlier in the trial dr
shannon curry who you'll see her there
who she was actually spotted in the
gallery today listening to dr use's
testimony she diagnosed amber heard with
two personality disorders
as a result of the work that you
performed did you form any opinions
with respect to ms heard i did
what were those opinions
i
the results of ms herd's evaluation
supported two diagnoses
borderline personality disorder and
histrionic personality disorder
now dr curry also addressed whether herd
suffers from ptsd
there are 20 kind of core symptoms that
somebody might
can manifest with ptsd you don't have to
have all of
them ms heard initially said that she
had in the first question you say do you
ever have this before you get to the
more nuanced follow-up questions when i
ask that first question on each item she
initially said yes i have that
to 19 of the 20 symptoms
that's not typical even of somebody with
the most disabling form of ptsd
when we eventually sort of dialed it
down she had three remaining symptoms
and having
symptoms of any disorder is common for
all of us some of us struggle with sleep
some of us get anxious
it could be several different disorders
it could just be that you have this
struggle in your life
but she had three specific symptoms that
i scored as present
um off the top of my head i might miss
one but one was sleep disturbance so um
she reported that she has frequent
nightmares another one was that she said
that she tends to have a startle
response so if she gets startled or
surprised
she tends to stay in sort of a hyper
startle
mode for quite a while and that's
consistent with a couple of things it
can be consistent with ptsd if other
criteria are met
it's also consistent with childhood
complex trauma which is something that
can occur when your brain is forming if
you constantly feel unsafe if your
parents are abusive
or if they're not present if you're
neglected
you can develop
certain physiological responses that can
stay for a long time in your life
so
i i noted that that would seem like a
very genuine accurate account where she
stays in the state of kind of hyper
arousal has a hard time calming down if
she gets surprised
you mentioned nightmares as well yes did
she recount for you the nature of the
nightmares
so they were vague uh
she indicated
that
she has recurrent nightmares and that
she feels as though she's being held
down
and there there was some conflict in
that account because
even though that could be a ptsd symptom
it is it is fairly vague but i still
scored it as present
and in her
initial treatment with miss
i'm sorry with dr bonnie jacobs
which i believe started before she began
dating mr deb
she had indicated
to dr jacobs according to dr jacobs's
notes that she was having repetitive
nightmares back then and that they were
related to her childhood trauma
and so that came up several times in the
notes dr jacobs kept mentioning that
thank you
what is feigning
[Music]
feigning is
essentially faking or exaggerating uh
symptoms that aren't present
does the caps 5 control for that
it doesn't necessarily control for it it
can expose it by drawing
how does that work
because you're not just simply handing
the person a checklist that says here
are all the symptoms of ptsd why don't
just check off the ones you have which
clearly if you're trying to look like
you have ptsd you would just check them
all the caps 5 because it requires them
to describe in detail
how they experience the symptom
where it shows up what it looks like
what sort of examples they can give you
how many times it's happened in the last
couple weeks how many times it's
happened in the last month
by the end of each symptom you've gotten
a very good picture of a couple things
one does it meet the definition of the
symptom are they getting it right right
is this actually the symptom are they
kind of confusing this was something
else
number two
are they giving you very vague accounts
are they giving you kind of a
stereotyped idea of what the symptom is
based on media or movies or something
that actually is completely different
from genuine experiences of this
symptom or are they giving you
a very genuine heartfelt sometimes
minimizing
but
it's it's ticking all the boxes their
mannerisms while they're describing it
the uh
very specific very nuanced symbolic ways
they're describing it a lot of times
it smells it sounds that all appears in
genuine accounts and it's something that
people really get wrong when they're
feigning
all right still with me former homicide
prosecutor melba pearson and melba gosh
you know they both sound so credible
quite frankly i'm listening to both they
both make sense i know you've had many
many cases where you have a battle of
the experts what are you looking for how
do you separate your expert from the
other expert
so one of the things that i always like
to do when i was trying cases was to
make sure that my expert is really
giving context to some of the evidence
that's coming out in the trial and
really referring back to different
things that the jury hears i tend to
like to call my experts a little bit
later in the trial not necessarily late
leading with them because i like to get
a little bit of evidence in first and
then have the expert kind of explain
that context to the jury so that they're
like oh connect the dots okay i
understand what this expert is saying
and how this fits into the broader case
i think in this instance i'm not saying
that it was wrong for the defense to
necessarily start with the expert
because again we heard so much coming
out of the plaintiffs case uh but again
this i think the goal here is to try to
really lay the foundation for amber
heard's testimony and for the powerful
stories that she's going to end up
sharing because no matter which way you
cut it if she has to get into the
personal details of what happened to her
and there's no way that she can get away
from around doing that it's going to be
painful it's going to be stressful for
the jurors as well as for amber heard
talking about traumatic experiences that
may have happened to her and the effects
that it's had on her to this day you
know it's interesting that you mentioned
the the order of the witnesses because
initially the scuttlebutt was that amber
heard would be the first witness and i
think there was a change in strategy
there they decided to put the doctor on
i think it was a nod to the fact that
this other expert had done a pretty good
job on the stand so ultimately now that
you've heard her direct examination
again we still have to go through cross
do you think it was the right move to
put her on before amber hurt
i i think so at this juncture i think so
of course i'm gonna want to see the rest
of the witnesses and the evidence that
comes out and then i can opine better
after seeing everyone okay so and so
should have been first versus this
person but i think at this juncture
having the doctor testify is a good way
to rebut some of what the plaintiff's
expert said so i think in some ways that
puts a little bit of distance and kind
of signals to the jury okay wait a
minute wait a minute there's there was
more to hear here there's more to see
don't just you know go with what this
doctor's saying listen to what our
doctor is saying and now you're going to
hear from amber heard and hear her
direct testimony and her pain now that
kind of takes us to amber's which is why
i've held off immediately reporting on
this as she made some very serious
allegations in it if you've been keeping
up with the discourse around it then
you'll know there's very much is split
down the middle over people's opinions
with there being a side that believes
her and people that don't think she's
telling the truth its testimony was a
complete opposite to depps where he was
focused on answering the lawyer's
questions whereas she played things to
the jiri now the reason i brought up dr
curry before this point is because she
actually predicted that this is what
amber would do one of the most
interesting aspects i found was that
they said people will often embellish
your minor details when lying so that
their story sounds more believable
they'll bring up pointless things like a
wallpaper pattern which they'll go into
detail about and in the testimony amber
brought up things like the carpet that
she kept staring at which she described
in great detail i'm definitely gonna go
back and watch johnny's testimonies with
this in mind and i also think it's
important to bring up the fake news
surrounding what she said you might have
noticed there's been a talented mr
ripley quote which has been said to have
been taken verbatim and used to describe
johnny but i'll look through all the
statements and couldn't find anywhere
that this was actually said out loud i
think everyone is kind of just running
the danger right now of doing
confirmation bias and i'm even at a
point myself where i have to double
check a lot of what i'm doing and what
clips i'm using in case they pin out a
certain narrative i know it probably
does come through in these videos what
side i'm on but i am really trying to
view this objectively and yeah just be
as careful as you can as it's easy to
fall into the trap with this stuff and
again just it's a really serious subject
so approach it please with some
sensitivity now code tv brought in two
experts who analyzed her testimony and
here's what they said
well one of the things that i did
michael to to really understand who she
is
not only as an actress but also as a
person so i went back and analyzed video
going back to her early career so when
she was on tell different television
shows and she took interviews i'm trying
to watch you know her different times of
emoting what does she look like when
she's just in a normal conversation then
i'm comparing it to now now she's in the
spotlight she's right here on in court
and she's telling this story about her
abusive relationship so when i'm
watching her body language i'm looking
to see if her words are sinking whether
facial expression doesn't match so
overall
what i'm seeing with her is this this
animated
overarching
overly expressive
expressions
the other thing that i'm noticing
where's the tears so i see her crying
and and getting herself all histrionic
but where is the the tears the tears are
not flowing she has these very rapid
movements she's jumping up and down in
her chair she's moving around and those
would all be uh indicative of somebody
that's feeling uncomfortable but i've
looked at a lot of video and i'm gonna
you know speak to your other guests too
in all of my years as a trial consultant
and i've worked on a lot of high-profile
cases and watched them i have never seen
this type of demeanor and theatrics ever
in any case i have ever worked on this
is the worst performance of amber heard
in her career all right krista i've got
to let you respond to that you seem to
think she was doing fairly well
uh susan differs
well
and and i see where she's saying i do i
did notice that i i was like i can't
really see there's that if there's tears
i questioned that yesterday when i was
watching um the
to
to this point though i one of the
problems that i've had
with both amber heard and johnny depp's
testimony is the level of detail
i've represented a lot of trauma victims
and you know as a trial lawyer we want
to rep we want to tell a story in a way
that you know has beginning middle and
end and it's easy for the jury to digest
here um
with a trauma victim you would expect to
have much more fragmented memories and
missing pieces and you don't have that
here you have a lot of detail and so
that to me is a little suspicious uh
when a story is being told but memories
can be brought out through therapy
through um through lawyers questioning
with evidence and you know maybe putting
together pieces for her but um
to that point i think that that
that is you know problematic
fair enough and susan i want to to
krista's point about the therapy
could it be in amber's defense she's
gone through a lot of therapy these
things happened six seven eight years
ago different times about all the way
back to 2013.
she's talked about it in court she's
talked about it with therapists she's
talked about it with her lawyers could
it just be that some of that emotion is
not there in the same way and that's why
the tears aren't flowing
well i think that she's trying to relive
this again she's trying to match
the evidence with the emotion she's
trying to hypen it up so to to your
point is that yes when a person has gone
through trauma and they go through
therapy and it certainly will help them
to kind of float through these very um
high stressful times when they have to
express what happened but here's what
where i mean there's just so much i'd
like to share with you if she had had
gone through all of this therapy and if
she had ptsd did she go through emdr
therapy if she went through emdr therapy
and somebody were asking her questions
that would create a feeder memory taking
her back into the subconscious mind
bringing it forward like replaying a
tape again she would more easily be able
to flow through those because what she's
learned to do is to uh nullify some of
those triggers so who's triggering her
there's no one here triggering her she's
being asked a question and then she's
going on into her own dialogue and she
continually um hyper uh escalates these
particular events does not make sense to
me at all
yeah i think i agree with you i think it
does i don't know if it necessarily
means she's lying but i certainly think
you're right i think she's trying to
trigger these feelings herself so yeah
very very interesting analysis of it
that talks about the performative
aspects of the testimony now like they
said this could have been developed
through therapy or it could indeed be an
act i really feel for the jury in this
case as it's definitely something i
think people will be torn on and though
i tend to look at the evidence rather
than the testimonies these will no doubt
have an effect on them we of course have
the recordings in which amber admitted
to hitting him and the witnesses which
are what i personally lean towards but
herds team haven't fully presented all
their side yet and yeah it could end up
becoming very messy now amber did drop
something that means depp's team will
have a lot of ammunition going forward
and she brought up kate moss during her
statement about the time she hit depp
for some context this called back to the
incident before with the security guard
and in that she alleged that she only
hit johnny because he swung for her
sister this is something that travis
didn't mention at all and amber then
referenced his previous relationship
with kate moss pay close attention to
depp's team when she brings her up as
their reaction shows they've now got a
new opening in which to travel johnny
swings at her
and i just
see my little sister with her back on
face
her back to the staircase
and johnny swings at her and i don't
even
wait
don't even wait
for
any other i don't hesitate i don't wait
i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him
and all of my relationship to date with
johnny
i hadn't landed a blow now why this is
important is because up until now depp's
team haven't been able to bring up his
previous relationships though people
like winona ryder have come forward in
defense of death and said that he never
showed any abusive tendencies towards
them these haven't been admitted to the
court there's a concept in u.s law in
which the prosecution often cannot bring
up certain things unless the defendant
brings them up themselves in either a
testimony or cross-examination a kate
moss was originally declared as being
someone that could not be used as a
witness to the trial by the judge she
stated that she didn't really pertain to
this case itself and that she was an
irrelevant party even though she would
have likely worked in depths defense
however heard bringing her up and
implying that depth was abusive towards
her means that she's now relevant and
can be called upon if depp's team wished
to do it the idea of past relationships
being brought into it also means that
they can bring up herds previous ones as
well so it opens the floodgates of
massively in-depth favor and means that
there's a high chance that he can bring
in way more evidence we of course are
now working with a week-long recess so
the teams will likely either be
scrambling to get this included or to
have it thrown out it's a major turning
point in the case and will of course be
back when there are further developments
i hope you enjoyed the video and again
yeah some sensitive stuff here that i'm
trying to cover without turning this
into a drama channel i appreciate all
your comments trying to guide me through
this thing i'm not going to get it right
100 of the time so yeah just anything
any feedback you can give it it is
massively appreciated and it does affect
the future videos hopefully for the
better now if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
other videos on the subject which will
be linked below thanks for watching
until the end i hope you enjoy the rest
of your week take care peace